um
any other one Founders up in the apple
orchard again
um good morning I'd like to reopen the
committee of conference on House Bill
um there's still some discussions and
some work going on and we wanted to talk
as house countries for a little bit
longer
um with that and with the timing I'd
like to take a break until 10 o'clock so
we can come back after we have
have some other discussions if that
would be all right
if not we can proceed but I know that
there's some desire just to make sure
that our the house position is solid
many of us have that same one at 11. yes
it's I had actually uh thought it mixed
up my times and I thought we were
meeting at 10 for the other so I thought
we'd have to break until later but we'll
break until 10. so thank you I apologize
everybody has a chance to go get a
coffee more leisurely um thank you
foreign
um uh thank you everybody for waiting
with us um I'd like to reopen the
committee of conference on House Bill
610.
so House Bill 610
um obviously deals with the the bail the
changes to the bail reform structure and
that's something that we are working on
in the house this is something where I
would like to make sure that our members
of this committee conference who are on
criminal justice are able to speak to
what our intentions and plans are
regarding bail reform
thank you Oscar
um
the bill that the Senate is putting
forward to us today is actually a mirror
of a bill that I co-sponsored with
Senator Abbas
um and I actually retained my own bill
and the reason being based on the the
numbers after the election it became
apparent that the electorate wanted us
to work together in a bipartisan fashion
I made that commitment to the um
Democrats on my committee and in the
house that we would work together to
come up with a comprehensive piece of
legislation that could pass the house
pass the Senate and be signed by the
governor
um having said that
um the piece of legislation before us
very well could in some form or fashion
end up in that legislation but as a
standalone bill I myself cannot go back
on the commitment I made to work
together to come up with a comprehensive
piece of legislation that had input from
everyone all the stakeholders that was
inclusive and open to everyone in
transparent
I spoke to several people since we last
met
and it was raised to my attention that
the bill before us could have unintended
consequences such as someone could be
charged with domestic assault for a
simple bump
and be held 36 hours
someone could be charged for a sexual
assault that was 10 years old and be
arrested and held 36 hours and in that
time frame there's a very good
possibility that they could lose their
job if a single mother
has her father come over the children's
father come over and he charges her that
he hit her
she could lose her children to the state
while she's in custody for 36 hours
I spoke to some people at the county
level this would be an unfunded mandate
there's no money included in this to pay
for whatever it would cost and there is
a fiscal note I believe attached
to the counties to reimburse them for
the expenses so there's a lot of a lot
of stuff that look goes into this Beyond
just the actual offenses so that that's
where I from the criminal justice
committee stand and I would let David
speak
and basically what I want to say is is
what he said and and
um uh what I'd like to say in addition
though is in criminal justice we have
the opportunity uh to to basically sit
in and hear uh all of the bills that
come before us that are related to bail
um and I think it's hard to sit through
some of those hearings without being
affected by some of the things that you
hear
but one of the other things that uh that
strikes you as you sit through hearing
after hearing after hearing uh is that
we have problems with the bail system
that just go beyond the way our laws are
written uh there are systemic issues in
the criminal justice system
um that actually are contributing
factors to the failure of our current
law to be as effective as we would like
it to be
um one of those factors is the fact that
police officers right now have no way of
knowing if the person that they're
arresting is actually out on bail
um and one of the things that's part of
this bill
um uh this before us today would
actually help us address that situation
now it would take probably a year for a
system like that to get built
um but if we were able to agree that
that was something that we would want to
do today then that you know then that
would be that would be relatively sooner
but as representative Roy said uh there
are issues with the other bail component
of this bill
um that are they're constitutional uh
number one and these are things that
need to be addressed
um and they need to be and I think one
of the things that we would like to do
is have the opportunity to put all of
these things on the table and come back
with the best legislation that we that
we can that has the best opportunity of
addressing uh the issues that have
brought us here today in a in a
comprehensive way now I I'm not sure
we're always we're going to be a hundred
percent on the same page after you know
after that process concludes
but um I my hope is is that we can get
to a similar place to where we got on
the budget just last week
where there can be components that we
um you know that we work on to make as
good as we can uh and we essentially do
the best job we can for the people of
New Hampshire to put our best foot
forward and actually create the best
opportunity to to solve this problem and
I think that's that's really I know what
what I'm looking to do and to get out of
this process
say that when we met on Monday I was
very much of the opinion that every
single bail provision in the bill was
should not be under discussion because
that's what I believed I had understood
but we have discussed
significantly and
the the provision in section four uh or
the provision that Senator Bradley
suggested
uh for the bail tracking system either
one of those would be a great start to
addressing the systemic issues that
we've been talking about and so I think
that's something that perhaps we could
all agree on and take away is a good
first step to getting the information
that people need to the people who need
it so I just want to make it clear that
I've
revised my opinion on that piece of the
bill and would be glad to agree to that
if we could take that away as a as a
useful first step
thank you Senator Carson thank you madam
chair
you know as I mentioned on Monday when
we met we've been trying this is the
third biennium to try to fix which I
think I heard you say this this morning
that you finally realize that this is a
really flawed law that has been the
Senate's premise since practically a few
months after this law was passed it is
flawed and we have tried over and over
and over again to fix those flaws
much of what you've said we've heard
before and they have all been false
promises we're going to fix this we're
gonna fix this nothing has happened the
Senate has led on this issue to try to
get this law fixed but every time the
house comes up with something else now
we're hearing about systemic problems
within the system
I mean enough is enough the time has
come to say we need to fix this law
we have compromised over the past three
bienniums over and over and over again
with the house but it's always something
else and I'm going to predict that if we
walk away from this it's going to be
something else and we will be sitting
here next year having the same arguments
over and over and over again
the time to do something is now we have
stripped this down
to felonies I mean excuse me to violent
crimes
we're not talking about crimes against
property we're talking about crimes
against our fellow human beings
and you can't even agree
that we need to fix this
I I don't understand let me ask you this
we have a list of these crimes which
ones do you want to throw out of this
we've heard domestic violence uh
representative Roy talked about issues
with domestic violence do you want us to
throw that out of this list of violent
crimes would that make the house feel
much more comfortable
what else in here don't you like let's
put it out loud on the table let's hear
what you have to say instead of putting
it off until next year where we're going
to be allowing more criminals to walk
our streets the police are angry and
frustrated because they catch these guys
and they're turned around on their
release right back out on the street to
commit more crimes we're making their
jobs harder we're putting the public at
risk what is it in this list that you
disagree with the most and let's talk
about that and if we have to pare it
down let's pare it down but I would like
to hear what you don't like about this
list because this is this is in statute
so I would actually like for us to take
another break until 10 30 the house
would like to confer sure whatever
enough is enough
foreign
um thank you and welcome back to the
committee of conference on how spell 610
I recognize representative Laurie
Madam chairman I'd like to first I'm
going to respond to Senator Carson's
comments um
frankly I'm I'm pleased that you see
some urgency in getting this done right
now
in fixing a bill that I believe that you
support it and you said it's been bad
since day one well I didn't support it
what you're saying now is save my bacon
we did this we made this mess fix it
and well we've gone to the house this
time that time that time my telephone
works and it didn't ring once from
anyone on your in your organization and
in your in the Senate to say hey would
you like to work together on a bill that
we could get through the house and send
it together not once
now at the last minute what's wrong with
this bill why don't you fix this bill I
listed what's wrong with the bill it
needs work it's not a standalone bill
that's good it's just an odds we made
commitments to come up with a piece of
legislation in the house and we intend
to do that
um your fortune telling regarding
whether or not we're going to be here
again next year
um I would predict not but who knows
that's just the way it works so the the
comments for the Press aside we are
concerned with what's going on we do
want to fix it and we're happy to work
with you to fix it but coming at the
last minute saying we're not interested
in fixing it or that we keep making up
excuses there's no excuses this is
constitutional law and I'm not going to
put citizens at risk of unnecessary
detainment with a broad swath without
looking at it to make sure that it
doesn't have unintended consequences and
this does we need to do it not with
slapping Band-Aids on leaks we need to
fix the entire piece
so in my position is that
everything you said is incorrect as far
as the House's position goes
and that's it
um thank you I'm not sure my question
would be about whether we're going to be
able to come to any agreement on this
section three I think what I would
suggest is that we do have agreement on
the on the electronic bail system and
the house position now would be that we
take the house the house position and
amend Senator Bradley's section four as
amended onto that and that that would be
what the house physician is so my
question would be whether or not that's
acceptable or if it's uh just time to
end the committee of conference uh first
of all I'd like to respond to
representative Roy he is exactly right
but no one's bacon is being saved here I
made it very clear when I spoke on
Monday that we were misled the
legislature in fact I'll go as far as
saying the legislature was lied to
we were told that this would not apply
to violent crimes and we were assured of
that over and over and over again we've
heard the term systemic racism here
today
one of the things I'm not excuse me not
systemic racism but systemic issues
within our criminal justice system
we were told that this bill I mean the
the bail system reform was going to take
care of that that we didn't want to see
people held who were who couldn't afford
to pay for bail or anything else that
they were not going to lose their jobs
they were not going to lose their
Apartments over small crimes and we
agreed to that we were assured over and
over and over again that it was not
going to apply to Violent criminals only
after it was passed did we start to see
it being applied to Violent criminals
and we tried to fix it and that's what
the Senate has tried to do for the past
three bienniums and each time we run
into a roadblock when it comes to the
house now I'm not going to be rude I'm
not going to be
inappropriate here
but we have to face the reality of the
situation this law is broken and it
needs to be fixed
we have tried with the house
five years we're now in the third
biennium
and we've heard all of this before so
the Senate has listened to the house
what the complaints from the house were
and we stripped it down
to only violent crimes only violent
crimes
we're talking about victims here
they don't have a voice and we're trying
to be their voice
at this point I'm just going to turn it
over to Senator Bradley Senator Bradley
so
a guess in response uh chairman Roy
um and I apologize I do not have a copy
of Senate Bill 248 in front of me
but I believe it is identical language
identical to section three
so both Senator Susie and Senator Abbas
sponsored those two bills and thank you
for co-sponsoring it so I think the
cooperation
you know between
the sponsors at least between the Senate
and the house was there
and we chose to move Center Susie's Bill
and that was in consultation with
Senator Abbas because
we just thought it would generate the
most enthusiasm to get bipartisan
support for now maybe that was a mistake
maybe it wasn't a mistake but I guess I
go into detail because
you co-sponsored the identical language
okay so I get that
there might be some issues at this point
in your mind but you know back when you
put your name on it you thought it was
okay enough to put your name on so there
are 12 listed crimes here and I think
it's important
to highlight what they are homicide
first degree assault second-degree
assault domestic violence aggravated
felonious sexual assault felonious
sexual assault kidnapping stalking
trafficking robbery
possession manufacturer distribution of
child sexual abuse image or computer
pornography
I've sponsored the two earlier
iterations of what's now Senate Bill 252
and Senate bill 248.
Senator Susie's Bill and Senator abbasis
Bill
when I sponsored those I think there was
a 72-hour window we dropped it back to
um 36. when I sponsored it
we also winnowed down to the crimes I
just
talked about the number of crimes to try
to make it surgical because I'm always
somebody that tries to learn from my
past mistakes failures whatever you want
to call it and not being able to get
what I think is necessary legislation
into the end zone that's always the goal
I support the bail tracker
I was the one that moved to the finance
committee to put it into this bill so
that we would have
the wherewithal to get you folks to be
able to say yup gotta have it it's a
good idea I'm putting Amendment on the
table that doubles the amount of money
for it because
the court system said they need that
amount of money to implement it so I
think in terms of good faith
we've generated that so
also
trying to get with good faith
if there are some of those 12 crimes
which we've windowed down because in our
view they're the worst of the worst
they're the ones that people put people
most at risk the most vulnerable people
at risk
but I'm always a half glass full guy and
if there are several of those that you
can list for us
that should be struck from the bill
I think we would consider that in
combination with everything else in the
bill including the two million dollars
to the bail tracker but we're we're at a
point that
um I think everybody in this room knows
there's a problem
you folks have admitted it
everybody out here knows there's a
problem
so I would ask that you know and I know
where time's getting a little short I
get that
um but if you could go back and tell us
which of the 12 should be struck
and we'll do the bail tracker with your
good faith commitment to come back next
year with a more comprehensive solution
that would be something we'd consider
so having said that I'd ask Madam chair
if we could take a recess until a
mutually convenient time and see if we
can get it done well thank you what I
was looking to do is as somebody who has
called the police on somebody I thought
was stalking me who actually was a pack
uh door knocker for me which is why they
were looking at me funny I think that
there's a lot of these refinements and I
I believe that the correct place to do
this is in these retained bills and I
would like to make sure that there is
strong Senate involvement when we do
that this is more than can be handled
before four o'clock tomorrow with
hammering out those details so I would
actually like to move that we take the
house position amend on Senator
Bradley's Amendment for the bail and
take a vote on that to see if we have
agreement we will work with you in the
retained bills but this is not something
that can be done by four o'clock and
just to be clear that would be just to
be clear that would be sections one two
and of the the bill as it exists and
Senator Bradley's Amendment correct and
if I may respond um you are correct
Senator Bradley I did correspond to that
and that was
um that was prior to the election
the reality once the election occurred
was we have a mathematical problem that
will not pass the floor there's not a
single crime in there that I don't think
is serious and warrants a second look
but but regardless it's not going to
pass the house it will not pass the flow
we do not have a republican majority
um and and I I'd love to help you but
when I can it's not going to pass and
there's a there's a risk of of losing it
and not being able to discuss it further
and it's it's to me it would be an
exercising futility which is why I
retain my own bill that had that
language in it
yes Senator Bradley
you know the speaker and I were the
governor and 100 other people yesterday
signing a budget
and if you told me and I bet if you had
told the speaker two months ago that
we'd be doing that
you'd have said it was an exercise in
futility the most dangerous word
in the English language is can't
okay so when people are at risk for
their personal safety I don't think we
should be saying we can't get a past
I would hope that you would take a
recess Madam chair and come back to us
with
the bare minimum number of these 12
listed crimes that you can pass today
and we would accept the more
comprehensive solution down the road I
would that would be at least you know
without having consulted with my two
colleagues my position where we're at at
quarter of 11. and we still have 24
hours and as Speaker Packard and I know
there is no such thing as camp and
futility we we put together a great
budget and I think that
is a testament to people being able to
work together and I think we have 27
hours or so left we should try to get it
done
representative Weber with respect the
budget was not put together in 27 hours
and
um
we have been saying the same words over
and over again
I'm not sure I I think that it would be
a great gesture if we did not throw the
baby out with the bathwater if we
accepted the bail tracker language got
that started because as we all know
that's going to be a very long process
and
put that on the first two sections of
the house bill and we can walk away with
something we've done good for the state
but section three is not going to get
through the house and picking and
choosing when there's only four of us
out of
397 or whatever we're at at the moment
we have strong opposition from both
sides of the aisle from significant
blocks of people it that I can't do the
math and get to a yes so I would agree
on the floor even if we were to pair out
some of these this is something that's
been a commitment to work towards a
solution this is the only the only
option that we have is to offer that
part of the the house bill so that we
can have these providers have parity and
include the bail conditions uh so the
electronic Bill system
um so it seems that there's no agreement
is it possible to research recess to
time uncertain and if there is some
agreement come back later or would we
need to set a specific time to reset you
would have to re-notice it okay
I'm not sure that we're going to find
any agreement on this I think we
probably should um at this point agree
to disagree because I don't see any way
to change section three to something
that'll pass the house and if it won't
pass the house it's an exercise in
futility
well I thank everybody for their time
and for their offered on this I hope
that we can have a similar effort as the
criminal justice committee Works through
these five routine bills so that we have
something that not only has bipartisan
agreement in the house but also has
bipartisan agreement with the Senate so
that when the
well yes but we need to have
I recognize that
I recognize that but what we need to
have is agreement in the house because
the house um is are the ones that are
that are closest to the people and we're
hearing more from our specific
constituents both those who need to make
sure that people are staying in and
those who have experienced some of these
Fringe cases that even though they're in
Edge case they're the things that can
lose a house or a family
um I I ask for your involvement with the
retained bills so that we have something
that's acceptable to everybody so that
in early January we have a bill pass on
the floor and if it's a Senate Bill have
a concurrence if that's a house bill
move quickly in the Senate so that we
are only six months behind but with a
far better product as opposed to a
Band-Aid
so I would ask for your help and
commitment on that and I would say that
that would be what is different than the
past three bienniums is that we could
start with a change and actually work
together from the beginning of a piece
of legislation instead of in both
separate houses and then trying to come
together at the last minute it's just we
need to be together from the beginning
and then there's no surprises for
anybody
thank you
um thank you all I'd like to open the
committee of conference on House Bill
um just to give a little bit of the
landscape uh this this bill initially
was around severe pain
um in sections one and two are changes
that were made that passed through the
house on consent and basically this
means that anybody who can prescribe
opiates
um right now well sorry right now people
can prescribe opiates for pain but if
you're going to have severe pain and
prescribe cannabis or do a certify for
cannabis you need to try and fail
opiates first which is a severe policy
issue around the time that this was put
in there weren't data around cannabis
for pain there now are so it makes sense
that in our current opioid
crisis that we're not pushing people
onto opioids before they can have other
things that are not as physically
addictive so this is this is an
important bill in order to make sure
that we're also not pushing people into
surgery to correct problems with their
actual spine for pain before they can
try cannabis because cannabis is far
more reversible than spinal fusion then
we're also looking at the Cannabis
legalization issue
obviously there was a bill that failed
and there's movement towards having a
state model there was an attempt in
Committee in order to bring forth a
changed bill that would address this and
I believe that the way that the
commission to study the state-controlled
sale of cannabis is to be able to make
sure that we have a solid look at this
so that legislation can be introduced so
that we can actually find a solution to
this that would meet stakeholders then
that sunsets as well and there are two
areas around the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board basically that's
codifying what they do already in
section five and then in section six it
is looking to correct What was seen to
be an oversight around hemp products
because the reading of it was that
federally anything that's derived from
the hemp would not be under the
scheduled drugs we have some information
for the U.S Department of Justice saying
that any of the synthetic derivatives of
hemp are not classified as hemp at the
federal level and so any synthetic
derivatives actually are schedule one
drugs so
it seems that the language we have
probably already addresses that within
our state because when federally hemp
does not include synthetic derivatives
it it's one of those areas that's
already addressed at the federal level I
would like to turn this over to Chairman
hunt to speak about the the layout of
the commission what he's been doing and
working very hard on this process and
what Insight he has and what he would
like to see I'm sorry excuse me I just
have a question yes is that in dispute I
if it is I want to get it out here on
the table
um I know chairman hunt has done a lot
of work but we have proposed a commit a
commission are you proposing something
different
would like to
thank you
and I'm sorry
a look at it in another light and that
would be two two elements of it or three
elements that we're concerned with first
of all is that we don't want to be
called a study commission we want it to
be a commit a committee to create
legislation for next year
okay so just some clarification if
you're talking about a committee
what are you talking about so we would
think that normally uh would be just
legislators if you're creating
legislation so that that is and I just
want to make sure we're clear this is an
issue that you would like to change it
from being a commission to a committee
to a committee of legislators legislator
for the purpose of creating legislation
okay so in terms of the task and then
the only third item would be is the
effective date should be
upon passage okay thank you
yeah I just and that's that issue I
think you know I don't think there's
agreement that this is the model and so
that's why the commission was created to
sort of study this I think if you're
saying this is a committee to create
legislation for State controlled I think
you're putting the cart before the horse
so uh the the whole point of this is to
see if this is correct for New Hampshire
this model and so I'm not sure we want
to you know have a committee just
already uh with the goal of creating
legislation for this model I think we
need to study it which is why all these
folks are at the tube
representative Weber
I just with respect to the structure
um I am thinking back to a wonderful
lesson I learned from when then
representative Nancy Styles uh chaired a
legislative committee that was tasked
with dealing with the issue of truancy
and what I learned from her that was it
was the year that she went from being a
a representative to being a senator but
she managed over the course of a number
of meetings to include every single
possible constituent in the most
inclusive way
and because all of them were interested
from homeschoolers Detroit officers and
school boards and teachers and and
therapists and community members
um
it was the most inclusive and
comprehensive work I have ever seen
and one of my concerns with creating a
commission and one of the reasons the
commissions have often grown bigger and
bigger and bigger is people say well if
they're on I want to be on and if
they're on I get I want my voice to be
heard and I think if you restrict the
membership to legislators you are
actually creating a forum in which
everybody
gets to have their voice heard it's the
person running the committee does it
well and we have people who do it very
well here
so I I urge that as not less inclusive
but more inclusive it means that
everybody uh who is a stakeholder has an
equal voice
and I think that that's a positive thing
in terms of the structure it also would
allow us to get going immediately it's a
large task to have done by
The End by by December but in answer to
Senator Whitley's point I
I really appreciate the focus being on
creating legislation
because it incorporates everything that
you have said obviously they may not
come to an agreement of some kind of
legislation and they may decide the
legislation is certainly not right for
but and in which case they could say so
and of course anything they create gets
presented to the House and Senate
afterwards anyway but I think that it
gives a focus to the study
so that we are
remembering as a committee
that the goal of this is going to be
something that would be presented
to the house and to the Senate at the
end of it and I think that that's a
focus that
sharpens the way the issue is studied
and and can take into account all of the
points that you made about
um
is is this right for New Hampshire are
we are we going in the right direction
but that's my my thought on it may I
yeah just send it so um I just want to
clarify that
um
you know I see where you're saying about
it being more specific to drafting
legislation and if I think if that's the
case then I think it should be broader
so you know it shouldn't be to create
legislation for state-controlled sale of
cannabis perhaps it should be broader so
we're not saying in the legislation that
we're creating a certain type of model
which I don't think everyone well we're
reading the letter of the way that it
was written it is written for to address
all the issues of a state operated
uh facilities okay we're we're taking
you're taking let's say the historic
perspective here there's already been a
commission
and they came back with legislation
and that legislation failed in the
Senate
and so we're now looking to you senators
and say join with us we'll a legislative
committee for that singular task
to create this legislation that's going
to have a state operated facility
okay we know we now have the governor's
blessing
not that that means much just means one
last step in Easton to jump through hoop
to jump through but we're taking that as
on face value that what our task what we
want to do tasks my experience with
study committees is when you have big
old commissions it it it's just a report
comes out and nothing much comes out of
it okay what I wanted to do is turn this
into and I'm really taking this as what
you guys were attending when you sent it
over to us with this language which is
focus in on just this concept
would this work what is it going to look
like can we address the issues of all
the different concerns and you'll risk
you list a myriad of them like the
marijuana mile
uh I think the one the most soluble one
that's in here that I really like is the
fact that we are determined to see if we
can do this to actually underprice
the illegal Market
and that therefore would take that out
and I would assume that that is
something we all would hope any
legislation we create would do which is
to under is that can in the state
replace
you know this illegal market and and and
if it and if it if they can come up with
that legislation they can accomplish
that
hopefully then those Senators who didn't
vote for in the past which I see two of
them here I feel that maybe this won't
work and that's why I just am trying to
I'm trying to focus the task on just
this concept and and see if this would
work and if not you know if it doesn't
it doesn't but at the same time at least
we know we gave the committee a specific
charge my concern about putting these
other people on the commission is that
some of them are actually have maybe you
know I mean I I guess the police Chiefs
I've never heard of one say that they
think it was a possible solution here
okay I'm not saying that I don't believe
that they would come to the table and
help help us draft a compromise
legislation but that we we really want
the people who are on the committee this
the the eight
four reps and four centers are committed
to to putting together legislation that
they're willing to put their name to
five five excuse me four four five
whichever number so that's that's where
I'm I'm why I'm proposing this it's just
it's just this make sure they really
accomplish something they get something
that we all can can and and be able to
level we can look at and not get bogged
down with you know who who what the vote
what to the commission okay
I think you wanted to say something I
don't wanna I don't want to step in
because we can I was enjoy I was
enjoying the bannering um yeah my
primary focus here is to make sure that
the underlying Bill gets passed I've
seen too many patients that have had
failed spinal surgeries that have just
been an option available to them to have
medical cannabis it would have been a
lifesaver for them in many many ways
um my understanding also is that the
reason that we're revisiting the bill
that we passed 20 to nothing in the
um in the uh the committee is because
there has been some movement
uh higher up that would like to see this
potentially a cabin and if it is state
run which has never been done before in
the country unlike our neighboring
states then you know a committee
commission somebody has to look at it to
see how this would mechanically work if
I'm reading the statue right from last
year that was just fast we already have
a problem with the committee makeup as
it stands right now it's five over right
so if that's the case then why wouldn't
we want to be in in fact in HHS this
year alone of all the many bills that we
saw there were very few that had as much
interest in participation as the
Cannabis bills so having said that if I
look at the statutes and the limits and
the number of people and we want to get
you know legislators involved which I
think we want to do and if the end
result is potentially a framework for
legislation down the road then I would
think we would want to have a committee
we can start it sooner we can have you
know dedicated people involved it would
be terribly all-inclusive because a lot
of people want to have their opinions
made and I think that would get the
majority of people but if we have a
limit of 15 people on the commission and
we cannot start for a period of time and
we have 10 of them already designated as
legislators we're leaving a lot of very
important stakeholders out of the room
with their voices needing to be heard so
to me it doesn't either way I want to
get the underlying bill passed but it
would seem mechanically to get it
forward with a state-run you know
operation this would make no sense you
know as far as the makeup and the
participation nor the bill I think is
going to get as much traction in the
next session as probably one for
cannabis so thank you madam chair thank
you
um you've heard
everything that you folks have said
um
we strongly feel that a commission is
the way to go we can change the
effective date and I have had a
conversation with Senator Bradley that
we can get going on this immediately
um it will bring everybody to the table
and everyone at the table has an equal
voice
and that's what we need to hear
especially from government because this
is going to be a government-run
program we need the folks that are
actually going to be in charge of doing
this they need to be at the table
so we're going to stick with the uh with
a commission we can definitely talk
about changing the effective date I
think that
um I think there is an agreement on the
underlying bill which for me is a step
forward because I usually do not support
marijuana bills but even I can recognize
that this is a problem that folks should
not have to go through these courses of
medication and even surgery which is
really outrageous when there's something
else that they can that can happen for
them and I'm more than happy to support
that and the other bill concerning hemp
we received some information here I
think we might do something a little
surgical here and maybe just reference
that one
I think it's Delta 9 thco and we can
figure out language to reflect that and
I think that that's where we are I guess
follow what do you mean by surgical
let's let's look at the language
um
when we talk about
oh God let me see if I can find it find
it here yeah
um it include Delta H
um or any other THC isomal isonormal
variant
um I believe and just looking at this
quickly the federal government has just
talked about Delta 9 so we can we can
cross out the Delta a
um or any other THC no it says Delta 9
and Delta eight are or any other yes
anything that's synthetic anything that
helps your synthetically taking hemp
that that is illegal that's a schedule
one drug so just like I'm told that
sudafeds are made into Crystal methodine
you know you know it's that process that
turns changes you know that from a an
over the QR was to be over counter you
have to get from the pharmacists with
your driver's license to something that
is illegal in the name yes please go
ahead I'm not sure that I read this
letter the same way as you're reading it
so we I think we need to take a beat on
because I I think I I don't read it the
same way that you're reading it so I
think we need to because we just got
this letter yeah I'm just reading it
here because it looked to me like
um
that they're specifically talking about
Delta 9 THC but I'm gonna have to go
through this um we just received this so
um we need to have it especially I guess
I also want to reassure you that the
Commerce Committee has a Senate bill in
our possession that we are working on
and that we would be presenting that
bill that would be coming out and we'll
be working on it this fall and we will
be sending it to the house for
that's Senator evart's Bill so it's not
like we were we you know this is not is
not going to be addressed it we we need
to address it but the the conservance of
the Commerce Committee at the time and
rightly wrongly because we did not know
either that as any synthetic hemp is
technically ill you know a schedule one
drug we're learning that now but that
having said that we uh we were kind of
in the original amendment of 639 that
was sent over that you guys killed the
bill in there was a study committee on
these synthetic drugs
and so therefore it's that you know the
fact that you're killed that that's the
only reason why this issue is really now
kind of bubbling itself up so
um you know in terms of uh you know
that's maybe you know you know whether
we the idea of banning something and
then making it legal
would be problematic you know which
would be defeating the purpose side but
now that we find out that it really is
illegal anyways
um you know so putting in the statute
that's fine uh you know we we often we
often repeat ourselves in the
legislature and I would just simply say
that's uh let's put a sunset in it you
know once we you know we find out that
it's not going to be effective you know
so and I like to say that with that is
with it already being designated to
schedule one federally then if we're
dealing with this and specifically
calling it out in our statutes I'm
concerned about whether that would be
the type of law that then would need to
be effective January 1st of the
following year if the state might then
be going after somebody which to me
brings the question because uh
I don't understand criminal justice as
perhaps we've already seen today because
it's a very complicated field but if if
we are saying that hemp does not include
these synthetic cannabis
does that then lose any perceived
protection and does that mean that
anybody who is selling these thinking
that they are legal that have a
inventory of them
what do they do with that inventory if
things have just changed on them I mean
obviously the federal government can
change on them but I don't really want
to throw out some of our businesses if
they thought that they were acting in
good faith and if now there's
potentially larger consequences and
state legal consequences it's my
understanding that whenever there's a
change in in the criminality of
something it goes into effect January
1st that may just be a freshman move but
I'm just I want to make sure that we're
not acting out of our normal precedent
and I do have one more piece of
information
where I got this from is from The Liquor
Commission okay and what happened was I
was tasking because uh in past years we
had the problem of vaping and so then
the resolution was that vaping is really
tobacco a lot of tobacco shops already
had it right so that we would just moved
it vaping into the enforcement by The
Liquor Commission the end of the day the
problem of this THC product is there is
no enforcement
even if we were to pass this bill today
we have not changed the enforcement not
suddenly and because theoretically law
enforcement today could be enforcing the
federal stat you know this this Federal
FDA but they but they're not and the
reason they're not is unlike when we had
uh the spice uh nobody's died from these
things yet not saying that's right or
wrong but that the issue that the
Commerce Committee had at the time was
that if if at some point in time that
this product was was okay it was going
to be on the market wouldn't we want it
to treat it same thing way we treat all
tobacco products which is that we would
license anyone who sells it in other
words anyone who doesn't sell you know
it would have to be licensed and then we
would uh uh require of that license we
would then have our liquor enforcement
would be stopping in and checking on
them like we do with all these other
facilities and that at and make sure
that they're not selling to anybody
under 21. I mean that's that's the key
didn't when it comes to Tobacco so
um the only reason you know where is is
is I'm saying we're working on this we
understand that this is a uh some people
think it was a a glitch in the stat
their statutes we're seeing here it's
not we've heard from the Department say
our DEA is bound to create rules but
they still haven't solved the problem
of enforcement
because there's not going to be any DEA
coming in
knocking on gas stations doors and
telling me get this product off their
shelf and so that if we really want to
do something for this issue
then we need we the state
need to create a process to regulate it
and clearly the DEA has decided that you
can take a schedule one drug and you can
create a licensed enforcement system
they seem to look the other way
so if that's what the attitude towards
marijuana then why shouldn't we do the
same thing with this product and say and
and for maybe CBD too now maybe there's
concerns out there about what's
happening with CBD I don't know but
maybe that these things are something
that we should license and regulate just
like we do with with alcohol and tobacco
and actually I'd like to say one other
thing on that I was looking at this and
looking at our vaping laws on the
E-Cigarettes that includes anything with
cannabis in it and that prohibits any of
these products that are vaping products
from being sold legally to anybody under
21 years old so we've had reports of
these being sold in places where
nobody's being carted and nobody's ages
are being checked
adding this into the statutes wouldn't
change that existing fundamental flaw
and I think that I think that it's more
important to make sure that we're
already that we are doing what we need
to to protect our youth from these
dangerous products and not allowing them
to seep out the edges and be sold in
places that that are not already
involved in the process of selling
tobacco and alcohol and being involved
with age-restricted sales
Senator Whitley yeah but wouldn't a
Prohibition be protective of our youth
wouldn't that be more protective of our
youth well evidently not because a probe
Edition exists already
and it would need enforcement well
that's our problem so this letter stands
for the preposition that those are
already Controlled Substances
it's already prohibited correct for the
sale and New Hampshire is just throwing
up our hands but what we're saying oh
we're saying nobody's enforcing you let
me finish so what we're saying is that
we know these are harmful particularly
for children completely unregulated feds
aren't doing anything so why wouldn't we
take the protective action in New
Hampshire that's what we're saying
how would what have you changed to
actually make thought I mean I mean how
many times have you guys seen this where
we already have a law and made someone
pass another bill and they're saying
well we we got to inform people where
people don't know the law that exists or
you know we got to do something that and
what I'm saying is what more if you
haven't figured out who's going to
enforce it right now law enforcement in
New Hampshire
absolutely charge people with schedule
one drugs they do but they are not
choosing to enforce this one why passing
this bill at this moment
is going to change that at all
may I respond right so I I hear your
concerns with enforcement but we pass
many laws in New Hampshire without a
guaranteed enforcement structure right
so what we're doing right here is a
public health measure to say to our
businesses you can't sell these things
to kids it's dangerous so that's what
we're coming from you know it's on the
businesses to follow the law right and
so just because we don't have like a
full guaranteed level of enforcement I
don't see that as a barrier to doing
something protective of children it's
not protecting anybody because it's not
enforced
so let me ask you in in the spirit of
negotiation if we were to cave on this
commission would you be willing to just
uh pass an effective date for this
statute out Beyond this committee for
the next legislative session so at that
point in time that committee can take up
this issue and resolve it at the same
time are you talking about vaping
this Delta this section of the bill just
make the effective date of this uh push
it out a year
why can you why a year if you have it in
the committee and you've retained it
again I believe we will resolve it in
the committee
you're so you're going to have an
enforcement piece we would do we would
try to figure out what enforcement would
be well that's true what we're saying is
why pass this now if we know that that
you're going to have a bill on the house
floor come January
why do we put this in why would we ban
it and then come back and say oh now now
that committee can then unchange the law
that just got went into effect because
I'm I'm looking at this representative
and I'm going you're you're me one of
your main arguments is enforcement
there's we can pass it but there's no
more enforcement
but you can't commit to having abuse an
enforcement piece with a bill you're
going to come out with in January I can
commit to that if you're asking me that
if that's what you want me to do is to
have enforcement
but because I would just enforce the
only enforcement is I guess somehow to
uh be you know if if the enforcement is
the ban
this product we're Banning this product
all together is that what enforcement
you want yeah I mean it's it's illegal
it's illegal it's a schedule one drug
it's available for anybody who wants to
buy it right now and what we're trying
to do is we're trying to keep this stuff
out of the hands of kids okay so how
would you do that
representative Weber I have an actual
question I have an actual question here
um
is there a percentage in having
the language
in the New Hampshire statutes because
there would be more of an impetus for
New Hampshire law enforcement to enforce
it as opposed to waiting for federal law
enforcement to come in
I think and I'm just throwing that as a
question I think that's correct and also
it's it's New Hampshire a law so New
Hampshire businesses are more you know I
would say paying more well if you if you
guys really want that then then I think
we should go back to this commission
versus I mean we've got to have some
compromise here I know and I mean we can
we can talk which one which one you know
in terms of how important this is to you
to pass this statue okay well we'd like
to versus is that that commission we'd
like to disco yeah take a break to a
specific time yes
just a question before you leave um I I
mean I'm okay with either commission or
committee as long as the tent is large
and inclusive of everybody so if it's a
committee and everybody's invited their
word is heard that sort of thing is fine
with me and if we can expedite it to the
point where we can move it forward as
you've been told then I'm okay with that
um but my question is when you're
talking is how would you envision the
the makeup of the commission then
do you know how that would look well
that's in the building right so so
there's 50 yeah so the only thing I was
doing here so the amendment that I was
wondering you would change it because
right now so the amendment I would
propose would be after it says five
members five and then if the word goes
on all those other people
um if I can we can also meet and discuss
this part amongst ourselves I just want
to put one more thing on the table for
discussion within our respective
caucuses is we could do a Prohibition
with a potential year Sunset and that
would give the house time to do their
work so that's something we can put on
the table and and just with respect to
the committee commission question
um the bill says notwithstanding the
um
statutory uh makeup that we've already
adopted and we can always amend a
statute that way by you know we're just
accepting out one and I'm not commenting
on the policy I'm just commenting on the
process so thank you okay thank you
one place
right there
it's already effective upon passage
which is fantastic we don't want to lose
60 days and start work in the middle of
October regardless of which way we go
the only thing I would say is
um I I know that usually the house the
speaker doesn't want Representatives
um in Concord in July and usually the
commissions start up in August so if
this passes I would hope that
you would go to the house speaker and
request that the representatives that
are going to be on this that they be
able to serve during there's actually an
automatic waiver for commission okay
good all right so I just want to make
sure that that is clear and so if it
does become a committee instead of a
commission we'll make sure that that is
authorized as well because the speaker
has the ability to authorize during the
summer months so this is a commitment to
work on this so I I know I believe that
we'll have that support
um what we've we've discovered also that
the commission is on passage so I think
that issue is
and with the
um the THC where we will offer
um a two-year sunset
through your Sunset to see to your
sunset on the law that will give the
legislature time to do the things I
think that chairman Hunt is talking
about I think it gives the legislature
things representative Leon that you're
talking about for businesses as well and
it will give law enforcement the
opportunity to come in and work if
another piece of legislation needs to be
filed
that's the the one part I would speak to
is what the business is if they didn't
realize that they were operating in not
a great space but a prohibited space
that if we put the the effective date
further out so that they have a chance
to clear that inventory it'd be good to
start that on January 1st
well I I don't know about clearing the
inventory it's illegal so I mean that's
that's a separate issue but I do think
two years is going to give chairman
Hunt's committee the opportunity to do
that work and if as they're going
through they discovered there's a lot of
issues with enforcement it will give
chairman hunts committee the opportunity
to work with uh criminal justice your
criminal justice committee to resolve
those issues and I think that's that's a
pretty good buffer of time
okay do we want to discuss more of the
commission versus committee chairman
uh so so where were you on the we we
want to retain the commission okay how
about the changing the language to
ensure that that their focus is on
creating a bill
another yeah
if I were to look at the wording section
four we could all always add a duty
um no I wasn't thinking in terms of
energy I'm looking at what's this okay
section
um okay so start out you started we have
four starting with for the commission
shall study the feasibility of
establishing if they control system the
commission shall create legislation
okay okay
um I'm trying to think
legislation okay so commission to study
State Control sales of cannabis and
propose legislation well it starts to
the commission sells study the
feasibility this this commission shall
propose
The Establishment I I promised myself
legislation proposed legislation so I
think so I think we as we mentioned
before that would be an automatic
endorsement of this and so I think we
could say shall study the feasibility
and then say we could say you know
something like if if the committee feels
like it is a feasible model then they
shall develop legislation so it's a
two-step so that's what I have problems
with because that if leaves an opening
for members of the of who are who are
appointed that you're appointing
to say and I know one of them on there
he sent me an email today
has said he knows this will not work
period
and so therefore why would I want
someone on this commission who is
already predisposed to not falling
through with what the intent of this
legislation is
okay
Senator Evart you need to well I'm just
concerned by by doing this are we is
that an automatic endorsement then of of
the legislation I'm I'm hoping that yes
that I'm hoping that those five cents I
I'm being frank with you yeah that we're
looking we're looking for a buy-in here
okay you know that you know that that in
terms of you know you you uh the Senate
killed Abacus Bill two years ago you
killed this one so you killed both of
them so now we're saying it's okay it's
your turn
it's your turn to put in a bill that's
passable
how about something that says um to
study with the purpose of proposing
legislation
proposing a framework for legislation
yeah
framework would then be pushing it past
this legislative session because if this
is going to be finishing up and
Reporting by November 1st they would
need to have that legislation but it's
also possible that with feasibility
they're looking at that a state-run
model which has never been done in this
in this country does not really
effectively work and that they have been
in the state-run model for one of a more
um
we're talking over each other um
representative Murphy is still
recognized that it'll be Senator Whitley
and then it'll be representative Weber
no no I'm all for studying it that's
important to do this you know for a lot
of reasons but on the other hand it's
it's it's looking at specifically a
state-run model so if you come in
language and I agree with maybe language
that proposes legislation but if it's
specifically to have a state-run model
then that may not work except for the
fact that you're saying that we are
looking at only a state-run model and it
may be that it doesn't work at all
representative Weber has a process
comment
this is I'm just going to remind you
that this whatever this commission comes
up with there are 400 members of the
house and 24 members of the Senate every
one of whom can and some of whom will
propose different models because they
have every year for forever and I think
that the point of this
study whatever we call it
is specifically focused
on this model
we've we've studied other models and one
of the reasons that I would prefer a
committee to a commission is that
particularly in the house
uh it's a lot easier to have buy-in when
the creating body
is legislators rather than a named
Commission because there is a perception
in the house
going back some years that some of the
commissions that have created
legislation in the past
have been somehow stacked with people
who are of one view or another view and
therefore that the commission work is
less valuable than it would be if we
could create
the perception that
everybody who had a dog in the fight was
listened to by legislators and that the
resulting proposed legislation was
created by legislators and what you want
is a diversity and I think the five and
five helps with this of legislators from
different perspectives and different
backgrounds and and unusually for a lot
of the things we study five from the
house and five from the Senate to make
sure that there's buy-in legislatively
for the product if there is a product we
don't know if there's going to be a
product because people may simply decide
wow we can't figure out a way of making
this work in which case that's worth
knowing but I I see no problem I'll stop
there because that was my process stuff
and I'll stop arguing the stuff that and
Senator is policy
I I do think a
um recognizing your concern about having
an actual piece of legislation I think
what Senator Carson has proposed is a
good compromise so
um I would like to say that um this is a
process that the house is delivered year
after year bills for legalization of
cannabis it's something that's desired
by the people of New Hampshire across
the state I believe that we basically
have the charge that if there's
something that's going to pass and be
able to make it all the way to law it
needs to be a state-controlled model
which is why I believe that trying to
get to legislation with the state
control model will let us see if that
actually is a path forward or if it's
just another attempt that's not going to
go anywhere
um in my view if we can't even agree on
that charge of the committee and
commission that kind of gives us our
answer if we don't have enough enough
confidence in a state-run model to even
be able to agree that we're going to
meet and draft this legislation perhaps
that means that the efforts doomed in
the first place
answer thank you
um
I think we just need to fine tune the
title and I think that
um I I would agree for proposing
legislation because that really is the
end point of it it's not going to keep
going on we're going to look to see if
this is going to work you're going to
get the people at the table you're going
to get the banking system you're going
to get the Liquor Commission you're
going to get all those folks that are
going to be touched if we if we have a
state controlled system and that's what
this is if this was just to a commission
to study the legalization of marijuana
it you'd have everybody on that just
like this but this is specific it is
just to look at one possibility of a
state controlled system and I understand
a representative hunts
um uh concern about this is just can go
on and on and on no let's have this
commission with the point of looking at
this and proposing legislation and so
let's see if we can get just something
that we can agree upon in the title well
commission to study I don't know with
the purpose of proposing legislation
State Control sales of cannabis it's the
the purpose the purpose is to create to
study and create so I think that's very
clear you can put that both in the title
so you can say commission to study with
the purpose of proposing legislation
then State controlled you can also put
it in paragraph four the commission
shall study with the purpose of
proposing legislation the feasibility
you can put that in two places yes
that's what I'm looking for I do we
actually actually already in six by the
way yeah and and so I mean
three we've gone we've gone over
a number of bills
um and you're right they do tend to die
in the Senate so let everybody come to
the table and see what we can figure out
and rather than
um just something that's coming from
somewhere and we really don't know and
the information is constantly changing
let's get our state folks to the table
and see if we can even do this because
if we decide if the commission decides
we can't do this then guess what that's
now off the table we don't need to
discuss it anymore then we need to look
at what other things are out there and
see what we can come up with and
hopefully by then the federal government
will get its act together
and they'll take care of this issue so
we don't have to it ain't happening I
actually have a suggestion for a change
in the commission membership to better
tailor to the need of hearing from
people within the state
um and then also staying within the RSA
That was supposed to limit it
um I I absolutely see the value of
having the Attorney General the governor
and the chair the liquor commissioner
um that those would be very very
important voices that need to have solid
buy-in I'm concerned that there's voices
that may not be heard by naming all the
others specifically
um and and so I think that perhaps a
commission that has legislators and
state agencies and state bodies involved
on the commission but leave everybody
who's not part of that state and would
not be running that state model so that
all those people who would be impacted
and touched by this legislation can come
be heard make sure that they are part of
the process but they're not limited to
just one representative from each of
these groups because this is a very
multifactorial issue you have the
Growers you have the sellers you have
the processors you have the testers and
so by having one person as a
representative it's hard to hear all of
those voices so if if I may um these
people were the members of this were
chosen very carefully based upon the
individuals that have come into us to
the legislature that are here routinely
and offer us testimony guidance on
marijuana issues so you know we have a
representative of the New Hampshire
cannabis Association we've got a member
from the ACLU we've got a representative
from the alternate treatment centers
we've got a medical professional that
um appointed by the Senate President and
a representative from the communities of
alcohol and drug-free youth so we're
getting both sides of the issue if there
is someone else that you think should be
on this commission please
like you say it's adding is going the
wrong direction for me right but I mean
I'm not even sure a lot of that Bankers
are still on here
oh yeah well you know why because the
bankers handle the money
so I'm just saying it's more in some
people the more the merrier but in my
mind in every commission I've and I've
been you know doing this as long as you
have Sharon that the commissions are
usually the more you I'll put on there
the more it doesn't get anything done
yeah okay that that the less less is
better so that's why her proposal to say
is why wouldn't we just limit it to
people who are actual government
government officials well if I
Madam chair respond
um I do think that these are individuals
that voices are and the the variety of
the industries and the people that are
affected by this I think it needs to be
what it is because we're dealing with a
subject matter that is
fraught with legal issues it is an
illegal substance according to the
federal government the federal
government tends to turn a little bit of
a blind eye towards it and that's the
framework we need to operate with so we
need to have someone from the police we
need to have the bankers there we need
and especially if we're talking about a
state control system you need to have
the Liquor Commission there because the
governor has said I agree you 100 they
should have it we also need but they're
government employees they're all
government well the bankers aren't
you
are you are you focused I don't think
you're a government employees
representative Okay so
let me suggest a compromise that might
recognize let me suggest a compromise
that might recognize
the importance of all the people on this
list
so what you do is you create a
commission that is five and five House
and Senate you add the Attorney General
governor and chairman of the liquor
commissioner designee so that's 13.
those are the members of the commission
and then you state
the commission members shall consult
with as Abby minimum
and you list all the other stuff
except that I I I think there were
concerns about the member of the medical
community appointed by the president of
the Senate certainly you could just make
that a generic
member of the medical community
by somebody it is it's it is a it is a
very genetic specializing
yeah I I get that but my point is if we
put all the other ones as advisors
rather than members of the commission
and make it including but not limited to
that
has the inclusivity but it also
recognizes that these are the specific
voices that we want to hear
if I may respond we heard early on the
the discussion about having voices and
everyone being heard
by having these folks on the commission
their vote I mean not their vote but
their voices are being heard
it's but it's the people who are not on
it here representative sorry Senator
Carson is speaking Yeah it you're right
it is a vote but these are all
organizations that have been involved in
the discussion of legalization of
cannabis right from the very beginning
and that's why they've been included I
mean if we were to sit down and try and
make try and make a list of everyone who
has a stake in the game here
I mean you want to talk about a huge
commission but these are people that
routinely every time there is a bill
concerning marijuana they come to the
legislature and they testify
and I don't necessarily agree with them
but I do believe their voices are
important to be heard
so I agree that the voices are to be
heard but when you put a representative
of a drug-free youth
there is no way they could ever vote Yes
their commitment of their organization
is drug free so therefore you're putting
a guaranteed no vote on this board so
would you be
um
of the um Drug Treatment Community
someone who represents drug treatment
communities would that make you feel a
little more comfortable like I guess
that would probably would because some
both of them were four
immunization but that's what I'm saying
this gets get away from this stacking of
a board let's just get away from the
stacking the board this is get the
people who you know that we allow these
people to come in and speak and testify
absolutely we allow them to tell us what
they think or whatever the proposed
legislation we absolutely want to hear
from them but at the end of the day when
there is a that final report and there's
a vote
you don't want to you know say well we
knew all along that they were going to
vote no
why would why how could that's seems a
little undemocratic to me representative
Murphy and then Senator ivard thank you
um you know we already went over the
idea that we want to come up with some
proposed legislation so from my
simplistic look at this we make the
commission five and five legislators and
with that I'm sorry that's the committee
I'm sorry you know yeah and then we
basically have we can list if you want
people that would be invited because I
would argue that you need to have people
from the atcs here the medical marijuana
Community you have to have a
representative from the medical society
whether it's appointed by DHHS or the
Department of Public Health and I'm just
saying that if we're proposing that
ultimately we want to get to legislation
why wouldn't we just make it five and
five and then have everybody that has a
significant voice be invited if I may
Madam chair we can't support that
because now we're right back at a
committee
so what's the purpose what would be the
purpose
um we we came up very carefully with
this language and there are people I can
look at this the representative from New
Hampshire cannabis there well yes
they've already said they will not vote
they do not believe any any manufacturer
would provide marijuana to The Liquor
Commission they've already made clear
that they don't believe it can work
and what is the purpose of having the
commission
um
they want private Enterprise They want
to go back to the model the bill you
just killed so I the reason I'm
recommending that the commission be
limited to the legislators the attorney
general that will need to defend this
the governor who would also need to sign
or not at least not veto it and the
liquor commissioner who underneath this
model would need to implement it would
it be it would give us the minimum one
with advisory members in order to get
those other viewpoints with all due
respect Madam chair we're going right
back to the commit committee that you
wanted and we've said we're not going to
support that we will support the
commission with the language change to
include
that there is an end point here that
they are going to propose legislation
and that's as far as we're willing to go
yeah I'm hoping that we can just take a
a minute because I think we are in a
place where we're getting very close to
agreement I think the other pieces in
there are very important so if we can
just take five minutes I think that
would be really helpful sure five minute
or a five minute break
okay
we'll take a five minute break I did
propose for the atcs to have the before
profit at one time
no that's okay all right so
much
thank you
welcome back to the committee of
conference on House Bill 611 aye Senator
Carson thank you madam chair I think uh
we in the Senate I think we've reached
an agreement
um and I just want to go overdose
um
on the section concerning the THC that
instead of two years it's one year
um so the one year son said so it takes
effective in 60 days so we would have to
figure out just exactly when that is
going to Sunset
um and concerning the commission that we
include language
um that says something to the effect of
that we are that
they're going to study with the purpose
of proposing legislation to make it very
clear what exactly the charge of this
commission is And in regards to the
membership on the commission we hear we
hear what you folks have to say and we
would propose eliminating the New
Hampshire cannabis Association which is
H
as well as Jay the alternative treatment
centers
but with the caveat that there be a new
section
that says that we will
consult with an illicit testimony from
these organizations
so very specifically their voices are
going to be heard during this process
and I would suggest those are those
organizations but not limited to those
organizations yes right but I I would
like those organizations named because
that you're going to consult with them
okay that you're going to consult and
illicit testimony from
um that's it those are the only two
um there was some discussion about the
representative communities for alcohol
and drug-free youth but if you go down
to section four of the handout that we
have you'll see the charge um in section
B is keeping marijuana away from kids
and out of schools so that's why they're
there
so that is our proposal as a compromise
and the other piece is that maybe
um the medical society should appoint
someone for the medical community
uh rather than the Senate correct yes
Medical Society or it could be DHHS and
public health I think from Medical
Society there they don't they'll they'll
be fine
um sorry and just some clarification on
the the medical professional is that to
look at the health risks of cannabis or
yes okay because if we have to issue
warnings we need to know exactly what to
warn people about the product and more
and more information is coming out in
fact Senator Whitley and I as members of
Senate Judiciary just received a large
packet of material from studies that are
being done or have been done at
Dartmouth so it's very important that
everyone has that information because in
creating a program you have to have the
enforcement section and you have to have
the legal section and it's about warning
people about
marijuana what that is and it's good to
have a medical professional there
yes representative Weber sure we don't
know how to do it
I'm just wondering whether there's a way
of
um making the language that you
requested about shallow consult with and
illicit testimony from at a minimum the
following people yes yes that's fine we
don't want to put restraints on any
person or any organization that wants to
testify in favor or against right any
kind of proposal so that would be fine
okay thank you
um I guess my one remaining question
would be if we're able to get five
volunteers from both bodies
um if that seems to still be the right
number of people
um if I may Madam chair I I think there
are more than enough people who are
interested in this issue that would be
willing to give up their time uh to see
if we can even do this
I'm assured that that is not going to be
an issue thank you
all right
um
sorry and then as a clarification I
believe that the
I apologize for potentially confusing
the two bills but the one that it had an
edit to the statutes on the underlying
bill was the other Bill not this one
correct
I'm sorry yes so I just wanted to make
sure we didn't miss an amendment to that
but I guess it was a section four
instead of a section five perfect so
there had been a in the other bill that
did not survive the process there had
been a fall been a wrong reference so I
just wanted to make sure that if it was
this bill that we took care of that but
it is not
so we are looking to
sorry are you taking notes on what it is
that we're specifically including within
there okay thank you bye
okay so are you taking notes on our
specific language
okay fantastic so we are another summary
yeah
so you would need another do you want
another summary from us
okay all right so I have notes if that's
helpful I'm gonna try to go to look at
this chronologically
um
the issue we have no issues with the
underlying Bill whatsoever
yes it
um okay let's see uh relative I'll just
go with this what you have here 611
relative to eligibility criteria for the
therapeutic cannabis program as amended
by the Senate
uh well no here right here oh I don't
know what they want to do this is what
so it would be
um relative to out
relative to eligibility criteria for the
therapeutic cannabis program and
establishing a commission to study
yeah you'd have to with with the purpose
of proposing legislation
state-controlled sales yes so that's the
first edition yep
and then that would be what the same
same uh language change and the amended
analysis bullet two yeah okay sections
one and two remain don't worry about the
amended analysis okay
um and then so one and two are unchanged
one
it's unchanged it looks like section two
to the amount of analysis is to study
the commission to study
um but it looks here it's a new section
three to study right we got it yeah okay
so that's where the first changes come
in where you insert the language
commission to study with the purpose of
proposing legislation to the final
um and then we are going to remove
um and renumber section uh remove H and
J so the representative from the ACLU
will now become the new age and K will
become the new I and L would become the
new
um J
um and then I think that is and then in
three we need the the language the
commission shall study the feasibility
shall study with the purpose of
proposing legislation the feasibility
um we also need to add the
um that the commission will consult
analystic testimony from at minimum but
that goes after that goes after this is
this is the purpose section right now oh
yeah so so then the purpose that
actually is not section three that's
section four the study show right and
that's the same study that feasibility
with um with the with the proposed
legislation and then but but but you're
right it did come before at the end of
section
two
let's see two that was just the numbers
so we've got the members but at the end
of the members we also need the
provision that the commission shall
consult with and elicit testimony from
at a minimum the following we could also
make that um so we start if you look at
section five six seven those are where
we're adding duties they shall they
shall they shall so perhaps they shall
elicit should that section should go yep
that's fine yeah okay so we'll put that
in here will that be a new session six
by standalone
um I I think as a standalone it'll be
it'll be a little bit more clear that
while while we do have an understanding
of a lot of opposition to the state-run
model those voices are very very
important well we're not gonna We're not
gonna say anything
I think that we just make it we need to
make it very clear that
um
that they they're going to elicit
testimony from
um these organizations that we've taken
out as well as anyone else so you can
add it before you want to do four or
five or between five and six but if if
you do it just at the bottom of Roman 2
which is where we took them out of
um so you've got a through uh what's now
a through J and then you say just have a
freestanding sentence that says the
commission shall consult with and
delicious and illicit testimony from
yeah at a minimum the following so it's
right at the bottom under J that sounds
good is that okay so so that's part of
Roman numeral two yeah
yeah
yeah and then in Roman numeral
four we need to add she'll study
basically shall study with the purpose
of proposal the feasibility of
establishing okay okay and I think
that's all in that particular section
and I think
um
when we come to the hemp project uh
product I think we need we need to put
the sunset in
um
I since we don't know what date it'll be
effective and because plus 60 days will
probably fall sometime in August would
it make sense to make that effective
September 1st and then make the repeal
September 1st of 2024 of effective 23.
you just do one year from the effective
normally you just do it one year from an
effective date okay so we'll do that one
year from the effective date so then we
would need to add a section 7 and
renumber the effective date with the
repeal
so you're going to be spending a lot of
time with OLS yes I will okay you have
my notes for me
thank you okay she got it so it seems
like we have agreement
I guess all those in favor say aye aye
other supposed to say
okay thank you thank you like your doing
business with you absolutely it's nice
to reach you very much thank you
with that we conclude the committee of
conference on House Bill 611.
thank you thank you
that is a huge relief